boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Sathyan we
are still in Cambridge in Massachusetts
we are now going to be talking about the
neural circuitry of emotion we have dr.
johann john joining us on the show hello
how's it going
thank you so much for coming on greatly
appreciate it had to be here I'm super
excited super grateful to Alex K Chen
for introducing us this conversation is
going to be lit I'm very excited johan's
background he's a research scientist at
Boston University focused on the
neurobiology of cognitive emotional
interaction he develops computational
models that investigate emotion related
disorders and you can find the links
below to neuro lodges Imam as well as
Cora calm his profile there and on his
Twitter profile as well and you've been
very active on Cora your research is
very interesting I'm super fun to talk
about the amygdala interacting with
other brain regions computational
psychiatry disorders we're going to be
jumping into all of that let's start
things off johann with what we love
asking our guests about their
perspective on the current state of
humanity so yeah this is a hard question
but at the same time I guess the first
answer I would give is probably what a
lot of people have said to you if
there's a mix it's almost like we live
in a mix of a dystopia and a utopia when
you look at the technology it seems like
we're in some kind of Star Trek future
already but at the same time when you
read the news if you're punishing
yourself by reading the news then it
does seem quite dystopic so I guess the
term is heterotopia the the future is
here it's just not distributed evenly so
that is kind of an opportunity like
there's a sense in which things are
going very badly in many parts of the
world and also sort of on the inside
there's a lot of anxiety and depression
and you know worry of various sorts so
you could even say that the world is in
a state of anxiety and
based on maybe some research that we can
talk about you could say that anxiety at
least some versions of it involve being
aware of problems and aware of possible
actions that could solve them but not
decisively taking any action on any of
them because you're never forced to make
a decision humanity seems to be in this
state we there's looming problems but do
we have to decide now can we wait with
global warming being the cartoon example
people are like well maybe we can let
the next generation deal with it seems
to be the answer of a lot of people and
I think across the board there's this
like there's all these opportunities to
do things but should we do them or just
have fun wow what a powerful synthesis
yeah the futures not evenly distributed
but it's here there's this there's this
utopic technological haven that we live
in at the same time a dystopic so many
looming problems that were kind of
pushing off to see how long we can keep
keep it rolling until we actually
probably take care of it I like that
idea of the earth being in a state of
like kind of like anxiety or in a sense
it's also we've had we have a lot of
transgenerational traumas that have
built up as well that we need to you
know be honest about how the discourse
about reparations we're needed integrate
that trauma into us and move forward and
in many ways we haven't done that for so
many things so that was of that was very
well synthesized and okay let's do the
journey of how Johan John became who he
is today you're born in India yes I was
and then you ended up coming to Boston
and pursuing your PhDs here so tell us
about this where you're born in this
transition to Boston so I grew up in
India but I also grew up in the US so my
parents were in the US right before I
was born they moved here in 1980 I was
born in 83 and my mother was back in
India when I was born and then for the
first nine years of my life I was in the
u.s. first in New Jersey and then in
Columbia South Carolina
and then my family moved back to India
so I was there until 2006 so in college
I studied physics and I also did a
master's in physics and at the time I
hadn't really heard of neuroscience I I
didn't know that that was a word I knew
about neurology and I figured that that
was a medical field and those days
neuroscience wasn't in the newspapers
like it is now every day almost and
during my master's program I was looking
at a list of possible summer projects
because the standard thing to do was do
a summer project get recommendation
letters get a little research experience
and I always liked using mathematics to
solve problems but I didn't have a
strong passion within physics I I liked
just using the tools and my favorite
field for a while was just mathematical
physics and so I was looking at the long
list and there were these all these
topics they all sounded ok and then
there was a topic neural networks I
didn't know physicists studied the brain
so I asked a professor that I was close
to what is he says oh it's a really
interesting topic physicists do a lot in
there and he had a friend in Madras
Chennai who was studying neural networks
so he said do a summer project with him
and it was a very interesting summer
project I mostly just read papers and I
did a little bit of coding but I was
quite inspired by this field it seemed
to tie so many things together I could
use math and coding which is just like
doing and you get to study humans and
animals and also you know deal with
philosophical questions without having
to get bogged down so I thought well
this is the best thing I could possibly
do and I don't have to compete with any
of my classmates for applications to
grad school because no one else was
doing neuroscience those days so so yeah
I applied I I'm just by fluke I met
someone in my pros digging a course with
me who heard I was applying for grad
school in computational neuroscience and
he said oh this department in Boston
University
dan wasn't considering at the time
cognitive and neural systems so I and he
said that'll be perfect for you and it
worked out really well I applied there
and got in and it was a very
unfortunately if the department doesn't
exist anymore but it was a unique
department it was a standalone
department devoted to neural modeling so
it is how a building full of
theoreticians and modelers and drawn
from all kinds of backgrounds there were
people from physics and math computer
science engineering biology psychology
there was one student who had a theology
background so it was great
interdisciplinary work it can be
frustrating but it's also sometimes the
friction produces too more heat than
light but when it produces light it's
great
so yeah so I started started in 2006
here at BU and my thesis was on time to
behavior so how humans and animals can
anticipate something that's going to
happen in a minute or two minutes and
sort of time their behavior accordingly
and that involves and also how that kind
of behavior can be modulated by drugs
that influence dopamine and
acetylcholine and you can model what's
happening in the mind in the brain as
they're predicting that in a minute
something's gonna happen in the case
it's a rat saying oh well in in a minute
the lever will give me food so there's
no other cue in the environment so the
rat has to produce an internal
representation of the time what's going
on in the rats mind is a philosophical
question as I said but we can study the
behavior and and look at which brain
areas are involved in which ones so
there's a region below the cortex called
the basal ganglia which is a set of
regions subcortical regions that's very
involved in a lot of voluntary behavior
and learning and so the basal ganglia
circuit seems to be crucial and also
cortical input tube to that area so and
dopamine can kind of speed up and slow
down an internal clock in one way and
acetylcholine drugs can do a similar
thing in a slightly different way so my
model
that I developed over the course of my
thesis looked into how that kind of
modulation can happen
interesting so was the neuromodulation
potentially had an uptick as the reward
was about to come and then it so there's
that the there's definitely so you may
have heard about how dopamine is
involved in reward prediction and reward
prediction errors so less known is that
dopamine also has a kind of invigorating
effect on just motor behavior you need a
little bit of dopamine in order to do
initiate actions and that's why when
certain dopamine cells are damaged
Parkinson's disease arises which is
often a difficulty to initiate and
sustain movements so it seems as though
this motor effective dopamine is why you
have this speed up and slow down so
basically dopamine agonists like
amphetamine or methamphetamine or
cocaine can temporarily speed up the
internal clock so this it's called speed
for the reason then even for rats it's
its speed and so what you see is that
temporarily the rats will respond as if
time is going faster subjectively so
they'll respond early but over time if
they're kind of running multiple trials
of this you know one minute later our
reward arrives they learn to correct so
they compensate for that shift and
what's really fascinating is then if you
take the animal off the drug you see a
bounce-back effect in the opposite
direction so their clock slows down
again
temporarily and they compensate and get
back to normal with the acetylcholine
drugs you have a complementary effect
you apply the drug initially nothing
happens and then slowly over multiple
trials you see a permanent shift in the
clock time so there's a sort of stable
delay which doesn't get compensated for
and again it works in both directions
slowing and speeding depending on the
kind of drug so that's an interesting
phenomenon called it really calls for a
model so that was you're doing a lot of
modeling and when this is all so I just
wanted to also
to give a big you know shoutout to these
these mentors or role models or that we
have in our lives that kind of nudge us
in a certain direction that basically
open up so many doors and so much of our
in that becomes our life interests
thanks to the little nudges of yeah
there is a neuroscience go and check it
out for a summer and then all of a
sudden boom you you know exploded into
it for yeah a decade the just the few
months before I decided to take up
neuroscience maybe my dad attended to
talk by vs Ramachandran in India and so
his his brother-in-law is a neurosurgeon
and invited him why don't you come along
for this talk and my dad was like what
do I know buddy but he went and and he
was blown away by it and he was asked I
asked me a first year student in a
master's program in physics is in any
way that you could get involved in study
in the brain and I was like no I don't
think so it seems pretty far from my
world and there I am a few months later
in the mural science project and reading
via science book phantoms in the brain
okay alright so then that takes us to
you your thesis and PhD work and then
that ended around 2011 2011 okay and
then okay so now I want to hit on the
the sort of interest in you know the
neural systems lab and emotion and
cognition and how what the hell amygdala
interfaces with the other brain region
so take this down this this path so I
work as a computational model of in a
neuro anatomy lab and what we do is we
are my colleagues look at the
connections between different brain
areas in the rhesus macaque brain so so
it's like a nice intermediary between a
lot of studies involved rodents mice and
rats and they're quite far away from
humans and then you have human studies
which are very useful but kind of much
more fuzzy in resolution so studying in
monkeys is important to kind of
understand the structure in detail for a
brain that's closer to a human brain
and over the past few years we've mylabs
been focusing more and more on the
limbic parts of the prefrontal cortex
and the subcortical areas that interface
with those areas so a lot of people
think of the prefrontal cortex is this
one monolithic new part of the brain but
it's not really it's it's quite a
differentiated part of the brain so you
have near the middle of the of the brain
and on on the underside you have what
what might be described as simpler and
potentially more ancient brain
structures which have less well-defined
lamina and then you have near the sides
here for me lamina there are layers all
a.m. in our way yeah okay so you heard
that the brain is six layers the cortex
but it's not exactly true you see simple
brain areas where you can really only
distinguish three or four layers and
then you have classic neocortex with six
and but in v1 for instance you could
almost delineate seven layers but so you
have this gradation of structure where
the areas like the the dlp FC the dorsal
lateral prefrontal which is involved in
a lot of higher cognitive tasks and
working memory has very sharply defined
layers well as these simpler areas which
interface with the emotion related areas
don't have that sort of sharp lamina
structure not as sharp and so my lab
started looking into the connections
with the amygdala and now we're looking
at the hippocampal connections and we're
very interested in what that has to do
with emotional disorders psychiatric
disorders
for instance we were looking into PTSD a
schizophrenia I recently published
something on that and right now we're
looking into the depression which also
seems to involve these areas and okay so
right before we get into the depression
and schizophrenia PTSD which were very
excited to get in there so this is a
neural anatomy lab yeah and so you
started kind of pointing out
different brain regions have different
anatomies and certain modeling those
anatomies yeah and then you're building
out this comprehensive model of neural
anatomy and then also you guys couple
that with technologies like EEG and fMRI
and and monitor the way that neural
activity works yes in with your neural
Anatomy so my lab doesn't do recording
so what I try to do as kind of the
resident theoretician is to tie some of
the the structural data with the
findings from labs to do behavioral
assessments so electrophysiology they're
recording from individual cells or from
like eg is this kind of a more fuzzy
measure so so one big task for
computational people is to put together
all these disparate pieces the puzzle
pieces of of neuroscience and and try to
tie them together it's still early days
so when I always say my models are toy
model ISM they're much more simplified
then even what we know about the brain
but in order to make things tractable
you can I have to simplify okay yeah
correct definitely and that's as a
synthesis I'm doing that all the time
exactly yeah so so then you are you're
you're synthesizing what a lot of the
neural activity data is showing from the
electrophysiology data that you're
getting and then you're making also
comparisons of that data to what you're
seeing in behavior exactly okay cool
cool all right
all right so um so walk us through if
this was cool you know we've talked with
you know dr. Adam coselli and other
neuroscientists about top-down
processing versus bottom-up processing
which is a fascinating way of thinking
about the way that we have our cognition
occurring but I like the way that you
said we want to have an amygdala that's
working for us
so a coordination versus a suppression
excellent okay so yeah teach us about
this so I can I can introduce it by
talking about a model that we published
a couple of years ago called the
emotional gatekeeper so my lab a few
years before I joined the lab discovered
a connection of the amygdala that wasn't
known in any species
twinny amygdala and a region called
ceramic reticular nucleus the TRN so
deep in the middle of the brain is a
structure called the thalamus and
sitting on top of it there's this
inhibitory a thin layer of inhibitory
neurons that's been described as an
inhibitory veil it is inhibits thalamus
it receives excitation from thalamus and
cortex and it regulates the input from
thalamus going to cortex and Francis
Crick for example was very interested in
this structure and he described it as
potentially an attentional searchlight
so it seems to be a potent mechanism for
filtering and the information that
reaches cortex so what might a
connection from the amygdala be doing
our model tied together some data
suggesting that this could be a way for
emotionally salient important
information both positive emotion
related and negative to seize attention
so it's a way for the for emotions to
get access to to be a gatekeeper so if
the TRN is like a gate you want a bunch
of different gatekeepers you know the
past passport please papers please so
you want important things to get through
and reach the brain and because there's
so much information in the environment
you can't just let everything through as
as far as we know the brain really likes
to keep to a minimum what is available
to the decision related areas in the
brain so we can say right now we're
taking in you know so much visual
stimuli so much auditory stimuli even
taste and touch stimuli exactly we're
only because we're in conversation
together we're really hyper focusing
what we're exactly conversations thank
you and but at the same time you want to
be if someone screams for help we we
should probably interrupt the interview
and go help or help and and so a
structure like so this projection from
the amygdala can do could mediate that
type of interaction so that would be a
forward what in the model we call
bottom-up emotional filter filtering so
even if you're not expecting a
particular emotional stimulus you need
to be able to attend to them
at the same time there's connections
from the amygdala to cortex and cortex
back to amygdala so here if if let's say
you have a strong plan you could use
this amygdala cortex amygdala TRN
projection to lock out irrelevant
stimuli even if they are emotionally
important so let's say you're really
focusing on something important and you
can't be too bothered by the dog barking
or something like that like the elevator
well the right now if you have a strong
emotional association with elevators
maybe so so so so that's an example of a
top-down effect that could be useful in
some situations
we're like quelling that exactly so even
though it's emotionally arousing and is
exciting the amygdala we're using the
amygdala to suppress other competing
emotional stimuli but it's the thalamus
that's this that's just part of the
decision as well well there's a lot of
debate about what exactly the thalamus
is doing it has for years been described
as a relay which is kind of you know
underselling what it does what we still
don't have a good story but it's it's
sort of like the entry point of a lot of
information both from the outside world
and from cortical processing itself to
propagate to the cortex so this is a way
almost like the reception center the the
amygdala is one of the receptionist's
potentially allowing things in to the
cortex okay okay yeah and and then in in
a classic model of of wanting to have
better coordination with the prefrontal
infrastructure with an amygdala
something like a meditation as we were
talking about before the interview that
it almost really does feel like
processes like meditation give one a
greater coordination with the amygdala
it feels like it feels like we regain
control over what is normally just draws
us to a reaction immediately rather we
can more easily slow down
breathe cog nice and move from there
so so can you just give us a bit on what
is is that a is that a is that a
conversation that's happening between
amygdala and prefrontal is that a
conversation that's happening between
them mm-hmm that's a good way to put it
the so the amygdala has bi-directional
connections with a couple of different
limbic prefrontal areas and so and there
seems to be the potential for a kind of
push-pull in the sense that the amygdala
can excite the cortex but the cortex and
the cortex can excite the amygdala
but the cortex can also inhibit so
there's two classes of cells excitatory
and inhibitory so the cortex so
different cortices have different
relationships with the inhibitory
neurons in the amygdala and this can be
a potato power --fill way to regulate
how strongly the amygdala produces its
signals for instance to the TRN and
elsewhere so a lot of the fear related
reactions that we have like in rodents
there's a freezing reaction just stop
moving but and humans don't always do
that but but a lot of those reactions
are generated by the amygdala going
downstream to other parts of the of the
of the nervous system and regulating
when that happens is a good idea so you
need the amygdala to talk filter salient
things both good and bad dangerous and
safe but at the same time you don't
always want to immediately react to them
so when you talk about coordination one
thing that seems to be useful is use the
amygdala to for the information involved
in what's important and what's not in
the environment but don't necessarily
react immediately so you want the best
of both worlds you want that filtering
signal you want that alarm signal if you
like but you don't want the knee-jerk
reaction and here's where a combination
of excitation and inhibition the right
balance it seems to be important and
go both ways excitation and inhibition
from ya frontal cortex to amygdala yeah
it's not always easy to map these
directly on to this circuit but you
could like for instance you could have a
reaction to something like pain or
something so that's coming bottom-up but
you could also have a reaction to a sad
story and and and that could come down
to the amygdala and produce reactions
that feel a lot like physical pain to
some people your chest could start
hurting your breathing will get altered
so we it's well known that for humans a
lot of emotional pain resembles physical
pain and at the same time let's say
you're very angry let's say someone cuts
you off in traffic and you're kind of
angry if for instance you find out that
there was a pregnant woman in the back
and they were rushing to the hospital a
lot of people their anger will dissipate
fairly quickly so that there's an
example of you know cognition and
emotion having that kind of more damping
down effective fairly rapidly in some
cases yes yes so many interesting
examples about the way that the amygdala
interplays communicates with other brain
regions and okay so then that's on a lot
of the amygdala side of things now I
want to here on the computational
psychiatry side of things on the
hippocampal side of things on the you
recently published on schizophrenia in
December and also you're pursuing
aspects of depression and disorders
related to that so let's venture into
this excellent so computational
psychiatry is a newish subfield of
neuroscience and similar to the story
with neuroscience I hadn't really heard
of it for a while and and then in fact
someone contacted me because of Quora to
ask me what computational neuroscience
was and then I was like I don't really
know what that is but I think I could
guess and and so I met this but this
person and talked about it and then
because I'm studying the limbic system
the amygdala and all these emotional
later
it was a natural outgrowth of that to
start talking about disorders in these
models so it's not just about successful
filtering but also well what can go
wrong as many ways the things it could
get can go wrong and that allows us to
not just ask what are the correlates
like which area is involved but why so
so so in the case of schizophrenia it's
again this circuit involving the TR and
this thin layer of inhibit inhibitory
neurons and the thalamus and the cortex
so we will just focusing on what else we
could say about this free area circuit
it's a it's a generic circuit so for
different systems you have the same kind
of motif we call it a circuit motif and
so schizophrenia is very complicated
disorder and no one has really found a
definitive cause or even a definitive
correlate but in recent years one line
of research experimentalists have
uncovered is dysfunctional inhibition so
there's local inhibition in the cortex
and tamping things down and there's the
TR and itself which has been linked with
schizophrenia so so we thought let's
look at this circuit and see what it can
do and what can go wrong so when you're
making a computational model you need to
fix a behavior that is tractable like
modeling hallucinations would be cool
but it's very difficult because you know
we really don't understand how language
is generated so getting to that is is
too complicated so what we found i I was
quite intrigued to learn that a few
years ago that one of the most readily
identifiable symptoms of schizophrenia
is disordered eye movements so
schizophrenia patients and sometimes
their close relatives have an inability
to fix their eyes on a target and for
instance you could have a dot on a
screen that's moving around and and the
healthy controls they can follow along
that dart just fine like going in a
figure of eight for instance whereas
with schizophrenia patient they're their
eyes will often be quite erratic and
there was a paper showing
that a machine learning method involving
a couple of high movement tasks just
using those could tell schizophrenia
patients and their close relatives from
controls with something like above 95%
accuracy so it's a diagnostic symptom
very useful for you know at-risk
populations and for the patient's
themselves and so the question is well
what's producing this this symptom and
Mike that shed light on other symptoms
so I set up a circuit involving a
simplified version of the the three
brain agent cortex trm thalamus and I
made a simple eye tracking model that
that uses the this kind of circuit to
maintain a target at the center of
attention
and what we saw is that these disrupting
a couple of different classes of
inhibition could produce this erratic
behavior and so so so that's something
that experimentalist can now maybe work
with we showed that different into
disruptions could look vaguely similar
but also have differences so this ties
into the idea that schizophrenia and
potentially other disorders may not just
be one disorder they may be a family of
disorders with different causes that
seem outwardly similar and I think this
is very important going forward for the
field and I think the field is more and
more acknowledging this so apart from
that diversity of causes story one idea
that we elaborate in the discussion
section is is the idea that going off
track is maybe a feature of other
symptoms of schizophrenia
so one symptom is having disordered
thoughts so it may be that if you can't
track a dot some if that similar
disruption is going on elsewhere it's
you're not able to follow the context
relevant set of thoughts so the same
disruption going on in an analogous
circuit might prevent up someone from
holding on to the line of thinking and
sort of jumping from one thing to the
other so it's an interesting way of
looking at how a simple local circuit
disruption can have these widespread
effects in different systems okay this
example was oh now I'm thinking my
imagination is roaring about all these
other potential diagnostic methods that
don't yet exist that will forget that
we're gonna be able to figure out and
leverage machine learning to be able to
more effectively um figure it out thank
comma and then also when you're when
you're explaining this potential that
that something as complex as a
schizophrenia could potentially be a
myriad of different involvement in
different brain regions is very
complicated and this is all the way to
when humans even in the womb and then
they're born and like there's you know
the foundational infrastructures that
get laid out at during that time period
and how that interplays with their
adolescent and adult like Zeca then okay
I have I have a question pre as we get
into depression I want to ask about
schizophrenia I've had several
conversations with people about how we
may all be this spectrum of
schizophrenia potential from a good
schizophrenia to a bad potentially
schizophrenia and how in at in and what
what we've created with hyper realities
where it like a Santa Claus it's kind of
like a hyper reality we've made up a
story okay and we and we call it real
and then people tell some people tell
their kids that that's real yeah there's
cookies and stuff and sliding down the
chimney with presents and almost of
reindeer etcetera and and then it almost
gets you know in a sense there's these
two competing realities are then
averring and so for and and some people
even say one of the most
potentially one of the greatest
measurements of of intelligence is one's
ability to abstractly reason multiple
perspectives multiple variables on a on
a given issue and so when you're doing
that what you're doing is you're trying
to see how like a low socioeconomic
status person sees the world how a rich
person sees the world how someone from
India how someone from Pakistan how
someone from different countries also
different genders different religions
how people see the world right so if
you're trying to balance all these
perspectives and see them all so do you
see kind of where I'm coming that in
this term and how do you feel about all
of that so I just started leading a book
sort of from left field compared to the
neuroscience side it's called the
sublime object of Psychiatry it's a kind
of a moral humanities approach to
schizophrenia so it describes
schizophrenia as a sublime object and
what they mean by that is it
schizophrenia has been defined by
various fields including biological
psychiatry and psychoanalysis as sort of
beyond understanding meaning that you
could maybe study it but you can never
empathize with the schizophrenia patient
it's a very strange book but very
interesting because I have and you know
people can relate to this they're like
yeah the person when the schizophrenia
patient is describing their
hallucinations or their overarching
world theory you can kind of make sense
of parts of it but the whole thing you
just very hard to understand what's
going on with that person so if what if
I understand what you're saying
correctly perhaps some of these people
are kind of torn between so many
perspectives that they end up with this
mosaic idea that that is a product of
perspectives that don't even sit well
together
it's a fun speculation but you know when
you're talking about disorders that you
have to remember this is a lot of
suffering involved in this center there
and so if you wouldn't wish this on
anyone
and especially the psychosis side of
things and catatonia and then there is
also a way to cook to as one potentially
experiences a psychosis from this mosaic
of worldviews and say there is a way to
live with that in a gentle way in a way
that creates almost a deeper degree of
empathy for four different worldviews in
that sense and so although it can at
times feel like it's a big taking on the
burdened to be able to relate to all
these different worldviews at the same
time it it makes one super well-rounded
and in that sense but so it's a good
another way to view this is just the way
that we use the social media culture
because when you take a look at people's
profiles it's it's it's only almost
exclusively their best selves and so
then that becomes you know what's real
in this sense what is actually you
because is you really only your photos
of you looking your absolute best
traveling having the best meals the best
people is it real no yeah so because
you're definitely not posting when you
feel anxiety or when you feel depressed
or when you you know you're feeling a
lack of love or you know so so here's
again this this this idea of what is
reality and how can how do hyper
realities how do balancing different
worldviews into a large mosaic how do
these things relate to schizophrenia
it's a fascinating question if we're in
a simulation or not these are very very
hard questions but what you said about
empathy I think can help we may be
ground this in something so I read a few
years ago a fascinating paper on
schizophrenia in different cultures so I
believe it was called hearing voices in
I think Africa in Ghana and Jena it was
an African city in an Indian city excuse
me
and the I discovered it through a blog
called neuro anthropology which so the
point of the paper was that it's widely
believed that schizophrenia is a fairly
universal disorder affecting around one
percent of people worldwide but the
specific manifestations of it can be
quite different so meaning the content
of the hallucinations is different so um
in different parts of the world like for
instance apparently in the West and in
America a lot of the voices are
potentially giving sort of violent
instructions of some sort
whereas apparently in India some the
voices sometimes are a motherly voice
telling you to clean up your room so so
there's that difference then there's
also the way in which society responds
to the person having hallucinations so
the paper talked about how in certain
tribes they frame this having of
hallucinatory voices in terms of
possession so a spirit is possessing you
and interestingly you might think well
that's unscientific it's nonsense but it
this may actually help reintegrate
people into society because when the
person is not hearing voices are acting
weird their belief is well they can come
join work because the spirit isn't with
them today and allowing people to be in
society and be a productive member of
society is really important and one of
the things you read for instance in that
book I mentioned earlier is that
schizophrenia is sometimes defined in
terms of inability to contribute to
useful work so there's a capitalist
element to who we decide is like
incapable of being useful so the way
that society there's one sense because
if you give them a big paint kit well
you know I often wonder if you know in
you know this is a popular idea that in
early generations people who were
prophets or maybe shaman might have been
what we would now call schizophrenia
patients so
so how the culture responds is important
and also how they tell people so for a
long time in America there was an
instruction to patients to ignore the
hallucinations where as what you said
about empathy is very relevant because
some places they instruct patient
patients to listen to their not act on
everything that the voice tells them to
do if they're telling saluting but you
could in the spirit of empathy towards
people outside these constructed people
that may exist in you are in a sense
perspectives they might not be correct
or accurate yes but as with most people
people just want to be heard and and
given some kind of consideration you
don't have to list act on every piece of
advice you receive but giving them the
time to be heard is a great way to
defuse frustration and tension rather
than ignoring people yes so so so
empathy towards oneself may be important
to all one's selves yeah yeah this is
this isn't such a fascinating back and
forth on on schizophrenia and I really
am so interested in it okay now let's
get into the aspects of depression and
disorders with that mm-hmm yes so I've
just recently started looking into this
as a result of so my lab has been sort
of expanding outwards this understanding
of the limbic circuit we started with
these medial and orbital prefrontal
areas and the amygdala and now we're
looking at the ventral hippocampus which
is a very emotional ated area and the
fourth region so I like to think of the
limbic system in terms of the four
pillars of it being medial prefrontal
areas the amygdala the ventral
hippocampus and the nucleus accumbens
which is one of the areas in the basal
ganglia which is you know strongly
involved in reward based learning and
things like that so with these four
areas you kind of have a motivation
circuit you have emotional salience you
have top-down plans and medial
prefrontal is complicated but it seems
to be involved in things like detecting
conflict and error and
sort of notifying the rest of the brain
that something's going wrong the
hippocampus seems to be involved as
everyone knows with memory and also with
context and navigation so these areas
seem to interact they have strong
connections with each other to kind of
help
an organism decide on a course of action
in the case of the hippocampus this
seems to involve comparing deciding what
context children is it a safe context is
it a context where it's worthwhile to
seek rewards the best time to invest
time and something or is it the time to
be vigilant and so what we're looking
into is the idea that at least some
forms of depression involve abnormal
context processing so it's the four
pillars have an abnormal communication
yes and and the the areas that 1/4 can
focus on are well any so because these
are complicated networks any disruption
in pretty much any node could cause a
problem and an outwardly you might not
know which node has been disrupted so
which is why we can think about a
spectrum of depression like behaviors
they may not always arise from the same
disruption but so when you're looking at
the hippocampus a lot there's a lot of
data on the upper campus being involved
in depression but the question is why so
so this is what I'm working on currently
so you asked me in a year what we were
what the model what model is but the the
the shape that I'm trying to take it is
that memory of the past and anticipation
of the future seem to involve the same
region hippocampus and closely related
areas and you might ask why so one way
you could understand the purpose of
memory is to anticipate the future so
you know it's great to have memories
just to reflect on all remember that
time but but if we're being good
biologists we have to look at everything
from the perspective of evolution yes so
now what does that mean that means that
at least in principle once upon a time
traits related to memory had a
and so selecting comparing the present
to the past in order to choose a course
for the future is a way to link all
these things together now what does that
have to do with depression it seems as
though depression is or there are many
forms of it some of them involve
demotivation so it's not so much about
sadness although sadness can be involved
as it is an unwillingness to take action
so there may be something good just on
the horizon but they don't seem to be
able to get out of bed to act on that
they may be cognitively aware of the
opportunity but it doesn't land with the
drive to act on it so one possibility
that we're thinking about is that and
it's not just me a lot of researchers
have looked into this but one
possibility is that there's an over
generalization of a bad context one in
which there aren't opportunities like
maybe you had a couple of bad days
people who are optimistic wake up in the
morning and today is not going to be
like yesterday even if they've had ten
days in a row of bad days and that's a
great form of resilience to say that
today will be different from yesterday
and this may be disrupted for various
reasons they could be prior trauma and
one big factor long-term stress
unavoidable stress is the worst thing in
in terms of human health and the basic
physiological needs not being met is one
of the worst ways to induce stress yeah
and you know but you know what was
social stress how humans treat each
other is the number one stressor yeah so
be nice to people because because that
the Robert Sapolsky talks about he has
this awesomest data about baboons and
how there's a particular tribe in in
India that they have so much access to
basic physiological needs like food and
water that they have plenty of time to
be cruel to each other
and and and the baboons at the bottom of
the pyramid the male baboons have the
worst stress-related factors and that
affects things like propensity to put on
weight and all kinds of factors like
that well as the animals near the top
are much better in terms of stress so
stress can be one way that a system for
instance of memory and context becomes
biased towards negative context so there
needs to be some sort of self
actualization and a self transcendence
some sort of a meaning and purpose and
fulfillment past basic physiological
needs and usually that means in a social
setting that you have these powerful
social connections and that you have a
goal that you're doing every yeah and
that you're these four pillars are able
to talk to each other well about getting
you seeing that opportunity and then
seizing it and going for yes so at least
some forms of depression involve a
difficulty in either recognizing or
enabling a good context to drive
behavior so it is it's a double tragedy
because it's it's not that they don't
believe that there are goals out there
or if they might have goals but it's
like some sort of access problem like
the goal is in to reaching you know is
motivating so the how did you treat it
is very complicated and so one of the
reasons that that mean we need to
develop a model and is to understand all
these different antidepressant
treatments why do they sometimes work
with some groups and not others and why
is there still this treatment resistant
depression population so once we have a
circuit model we can look at different
kinds of defects and see well which
treatments might compensate for which
defects and then we in future we might
even be able to target things much
better if we can find behavioral clues
for well this is depression type A or
depression type B that would be ideal I
can't promise anything like that anytime
soon but that's the goal of theoretical
neuroscience
yeah one of those yes yeah totally if
you can maybe you know find a power-law
distribution in depression and
unidentified that a lot of cases follow
a type a let's say or or yeah yeah yeah
and type B is less and it's like it
looks like this it cetera yeah um
actually what you're teaching about
about memory the use of memory is
something that we find very fascinating
in that you know and the way that you
know what sleeps involvement in that
process as well and just if one's
ability to look at the stimuli that
they've collected throughout their lives
as as their memory and then how a
computer carries almost a hundred
percent retention of memory whereas we
carry whatever way less of stimuli that
we've absorbed right so like a robotics
intelligent perception could carry
almost infinite if it's being you know
stored and and it's so crazy how we then
compute the day's stimuli with our
storage of memory and then figure out
what the best future actions are to take
that whole that feedback system that we
have is so freakin crazy
yes crazy is but yeah and you know it's
good that you mention the computer
because it's very popular to understand
human memory in terms of computer memory
but it's also very important to
understand why they are wildly different
like for instance see in a hard drive as
you pack it with memory eventually it
starts to do worse like the the more
memories it holds but whereas with human
memory the more links you have the
better your memory is because you can
make more connections so associative
memory is very different from computer
memory so see it every memory you'd be
like if the memory of the computer was
learning exactly why you and so that the
term that's used in computer science and
machine learning is content-addressable
memory
we haven't made particularly good
content addressable memory and what that
so it's what does that mean
it's it's that if if I talk about say a
Beatles song I have all kinds of related
information near the address of Beatles
whereas if I have a folder full of mp3s
of the Beatles I can't be like well
which of the songs that are about such
and such topic or which which are the
ones that are because unless I saved it
with with tags or something in the first
place the like have you ever tried to
search on an uninvited oh it's so bad so
use interesting you're talking about
querying your own memory verses on a
computer I'm sending a query Z it's much
harder but but for for the files that
you've indexed locally but sending a
query to a search engine different Wow
because they're doing the connect
associating yeah we're doing like we're
doing the work for Google wow wow wow
and then it's it's almost as though
every single than gmail address that is
linked as it's making queries is then
creating this massive yeah interplay
between the one that's making the
queries and the actual database but
exactly building out the massive model
of what that what the queries have been
happening and then rejecting about
what's gonna be of interest and all that
type of stuff but my favorite version of
this is which is a mysterious and I have
no idea how to model it is let's say
you've heard a bunch of music and you
have that in your memory somewhere and
someone introduces you to a new term
let's say a Chandra name you can
retroactively Li say that oh that song I
heard a month ago is in this genre so
this new information can can immediately
kind of go work back with prior memories
so you can take new information and
completely recontextualize reorder every
file all memories on the fly with no
effort yeah oh man yeah that's um that's
like when you when maybe you experienced
some profound awareness shift in a
scientific field or something and you
really go back and you and you you
realize that the way you
maybe storing the the the knowledge
before could be updated in such a cool
way with the new information that it
like makes it more easy to recall the
writer of knowledge basis yeah wow that
that was such a profoundly fascinating
conversation I loved it awesome that was
so cool on all things neural circuitry
of emotion and also I want to ask you a
couple quick questions on the way out of
the show like we like to ask on every
episode two of them the first question
is are we in a simulation
I find the thought somewhat meaningless
in the sense that I don't think it
matters because we can't step out of it
so whatever we see is the the real world
for all practical purposes so it's fun
to speculate about but I don't think it
can ever have any consequences for our
decisions or even for our experience
really it's a bit like you know the new
version of are all of us in the dream of
Vishnu kind of thing you know like it's
an assist another version of that until
we can actually poke with a scientific
probe at the simulation and also make
our own simulation so we get to let you
know do both experiments at the same
time potentially the opponent is a bit
harder importantly if you were before I
don't know whether that's even possible
but if there is even possible we have to
figure out nothing and potentially it's
impossible that's okay and then the last
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world well it's a very hard
question but I'm gonna say it's the most
beautiful thing
I don't know whether it's beautiful or
not but I love analogies metaphors and
analogies and it's almost not just
beautiful in itself but it's one of the
ways by which we can access many forms
of beauty and the more you study it the
more beautiful it becomes in itself
partly because of the mystery of it like
show me the machine learning model that
can produce and understand analysis then
we'll have artificial intelligence yeah
and as a synthesis metaphors and
analogies are so crucial and if you can
if we can refine something of sheer vast
complexity into a very powerful metaphor
like right now we've been working so
much with this idea of a tree of
possibility and the seed so that every
mind of her child is a seed born into
the world it needs to write nutrients in
the root system the basic physiological
needs in order for it to flourish and
have lots of fruit for the community
family in the world and then also the
tree of possibility that there's so many
different roads that the seed can take
in its life the jobs it takes the
interest that it takes the people at
Mary it said that you marry children
that you have all these types of we live
so these analogies and metaphors they
can drive expanded states of awareness
in such a simple form that can get
passed on for potentially centuries yeah
so yeah yeah I'm really happy that you
said that's the first time we've heard
that as the most beautiful thing in the
world meditate no I said that was the
first time we hear that okay Johan thank
you so much for coming on to the show
Thank You Alan this was great this is
such a pleasure brother thank you thank
you yes and I really hope that everyone
that watch that you guys had a great
time please let us know your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode go and
share this type of content with other
people get talking to more people about
our brain regions how we interact with
the world what that means for ourselves
and for our friends and communities and
our what we've what we
we seek as azar as our ultimate callings
in life and also support the people that
you believe in Yohan's links are below
support him follow him also simulations
links are below support the artists and
entrepreneurs and the organizations
around the world that you believe in and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace